la parole est maintenant monsieur didier
guillaume président du groupe socialiste
et républicain du sénat monsieur
guillaume vous avez la parole pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les députés et
sénateurs chers collègues
en démocratie le peuple a toujours
raison et certaines organisations sont
mortes pour l'avoir oublié
alors quelques instants pour essayer de
réfléchir sur qu'at-il voulu exprimer
dans ces élections peut-être plus que
tout sa lassitude son exaspération même
du jeu politique qui se pratique depuis
des années routinier caricatural un jeu
de réflexe plutôt qu'un jeu de réflexion
cette exaspération s'est exprimé avec
force au point de bouleverser le paysage
politique
c'est parti et ses groupes
parlementaires il est donc désormais de
notre responsabilité nous par le mat
parlementaire de la république française
de répondre à cette exaspération
sinon viendra bientôt le temps de la
colère une exigence de réussite donc se
posent à nous ceux qui pensent pouvoir
rétablir l'ancien monde n'ont pas saisi
l'ampleur de ce scrutin mais ceux qui
pensent que nous sommes à l'an 1 de la
politique oblige notre histoire riche
oublie ceux qui nous ont précédés oublie
les grandeur de notre république
alors certes nous devons inventer créer
dépasser mais nous devons surtout être à
la hauteur à la hauteur de cette
histoire à la hauteur des attentes de
nos concitoyens à la hauteur de la
france le président de la république a
tracé la feuille de route et demain et
après demain monsieur le premier
ministre à l'assemblée au sénat
vous même vous mettrez en application
cette feuille de route et vous
présenterez le groupe programme
gouvernemental et nous aurons l'occasion
d'en débattre avec vous je veux donc me
contenter exclusivement d'évoquer deux
parler de la feuille de route que le
président de la république a présenté à
l'instant une fois par an at il dit un
grand rendez vous démocratique
chiche par leur absence certains ont
d'emblée renoncé à faire ce travail
d'invention et de créativité
ils sont réfugiés dans un confort de
posture qu'il maîtrise à merveille
mais au nom du groupe que je représente
je prends ce congrès la présence du
président de la république comme une
marque de respect une opportunité pour
nouer un débat utile au pays
mais monsieur le premier ministre nous
voulons formulé une proposition que
chaque année à l'occasion du message du
président a adressé au parlement le
président puisse répondre aux
parlementaires en effet nous sommes là
les uns et les autres à la tribune alors
que le président de la république est
partie et nous adressons à vous il ne
peut pas attendre que nous avons à nous
dire aussi nous ferons la prod nous
allons présenter une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle madame la garde des
sceaux afin d'en un changement de
constitution dont jugent sûrs que le
gouvernement et la majorité sera
favorable l'année prochaine le président
de la république pourra écouter ce
qu'ils ont à dire
les présidents de groupe et pour en
débattre avec lui
nous sommes le seul pays au monde où le
président de la république ne peut pas
débattre avec des parlementaires le seul
oui comme le président de la république
l'a dit nos institutions besoin d'être
renforcée lors délitement est le pendant
d'une défiance citoyenne qui grandit
année après année
mais attention on ne joue pas à la
loterie au bonneteau avec nos
institutions
celles ci méritent d'être renforcée
mérite d'avancer mais il faut vraiment
être lucide
la crise est profonde le populisme est
toujours là il ne s'incarne pas
uniquement dans le projet de l'extrême
droite il est une atmosphère et une
humeur qui se répondent partout en
france dans les villes comme dans les
zones rurales et je crois que le lien
démocratique abîmé entre nos concitoyens
et la classe politique
peut être rétablis si nous savons suivre
la proposition que vous faites de
changement démocratique et de
changements institutionnels importants
le gouvernement je crois en est
conscient et monsieur le préfet me
disent vous présenterez des projets dans
les mois qui viennent nous nous aurons
l'occasion d'en débattre
jour et nuit et là encore je souhaite
contribuer à ce débat dans une démarche
résolument constructive car nos
institutions sont solides la vème
république a tenu et tient encore
aujourd'hui et ceux qui voudrait
dépasser la vème république pour 20
mètres une sixième qu'il réfléchisse
bien à ce que nous avons vécu et à la
solidité de cette de cette constitution
par notre action nous par nos décisions
nous devons relever cinq dépit celui de
la stabilité du régime de l'efficacité
de la prise de décision de la meilleure
représentation du peuple français de la
participation des citoyens et de la
clarté de la transparence dans l'action
publique mais un mot qui a été évoqué
tout à l'air sur lequel je veux revenir
attention danger
le populisme est l'anti parlementarisme
ne peuvent pas être érigée en ligne de
conduite dans la vie démocratique de ce
pays et parfois même nous pouvons nous y
souscrire
alors mes chers collègues faisons au cet
après midi
le pacte de versailles parce que nous
sommes des parlementaires français des
parlementaires de la république
nous allons proscrire tout le temps le
populisme parce que le populisme va
beaucoup trop loin et qu'un c'est nous
qui l'embryon alors le peuple est sûr
d'avoir raison
attention à cela ça pourrait nous amener
des lendemains difficiles
je conclu monsieur le président pour
répondre aux projets d'amélioration de
nos institutions
annoncé par le président de la
république la proportionnelle une dose
conséquente
chez le premier ministre c'est pas une
dose de ses pas une dose de
proportionnelle qu'il faut c'est une
grosse dose de proportionnelle
conséquente
parce qu'une petite dose ne changerait
rien
et j'ai entendu l'oratrice précédente
qui dit rien ne va il faut tout changer
mais au bout du compte rien ne doit
changer
et bien non il faut changer les choses
et la proportionnelle peut aider à le
faire et une meilleure représentation
des courants politiques de même que
réduire le nombre de parlementaires
ce n'est pas parce que les français ne
veulent pas ce que les français si on
les pousse au bout ils nous diront mais
il en faut deux fois moins trois fois
moins quatre fois moyen aura toujours
trop mais la limitation du cumul des
mandats engagée par le président
hollande et par la présidente majorité
que vous allez prolongé aujourd'hui nous
montrera que nous aurons besoin de moins
de parlementaire pour faire le même
travail et nous y serons favorable mais
dans ce cadre là je veux réaffirmer ici
devant le président du sénat que nous
nous souhaitons que le bicamérisme reste
le fondement de nos institutions
un bicamérisme rénové un bicamérisme qui
bouge le président larcher a fait déjà
beaucoup de propositions
mais ce bicamérisme là il est le gage de
la stabilité de nos institutions
enfin mes chers collègues pour conclure
je voudrais revenir sur la crise grave
que traverse notre pays tous ici en aux
diverses fonctions et qualité nous avons
une part de responsabilité mais surtout
nous devons avoir la volonté d'y
rémédier pas uniquement de faire des
commentaires oui d'y rémédier réellement
c'est notre rôle de parlementaire
assumons le redonner sa place à
l'intelligence française
oui mais c'est faire aussi vivre la
république tous les jours quelles que
soient les endroits où nous habitons
redonner sa place à l'intelligence
française c'est assumer notre engagement
européen et nous devons en être fiers
alors la promesse républicaine est
d'abord une promesse démocratique
nos concitoyens veulent mieux maîtriser
leur vie leur destin leur vivant femmes
dans la république est essentiel dans
tous les territoires dans les corons du
bassin minier
inca marques comme au pays basque cette
france est une et indivisible
elle est diverse mais elle est une et
indivisible aussi je souhaite ardemment
que ce quinquennat soit celui de la
réaffirmation de la république
et de ses valeurs et nous en avons
besoin notre pays a connu des drames
terribles des traumatismes il est en
guerre contre le terrorisme islamiste
l'euphorie électorale elle est légitime
de ces dernières semaines ne doit pas
rien effacé de tout cela les fractures
de la société sont toujours là
n'oublions pas le 16 novembre 2015 ici
même dans cet hémicycle ou debout les
900 et quelques parlementaires étaient
dans une haie de silence et après en
chantant la marseillaise unis dans les
valeurs républicaines contre le
terrorisme
n'oublions pas ce poison de la
république qu'est le communautarisme
continuons d'affirmer pleinement nos
valeurs républicaines et un peu un
premier lieu la laïcité laïcité seule
capable de répondre aux défis qui sont
devant nous alors travaillant à tout
cela pour réformer la france et
promouvoir la république
le président a tracé sa feuille de route
monsieur le premier ministre nous en
débattrons sans réserve dans l'intérêt
de la france et des français car c'est
l'honneur du parlement de pouvoir
construire l'avenir de notre pays
soyons à la hauteur de nos concitoyens
soyons à la hauteur pour la république
et pour la france je vous remercie
merci monsieur guillaume la parole est
maintenant monsieur marc fesneau du
groupe mouvement démocrate et apparentés
de l'assemblée nationale vous avez la
parole monsieur finaux pour 10 minutes
maximum